the latest fantastic bees film might
just hold more secrets than dumbledore
himself do you want to learn more about
the deluminator or clever references to
the previous films keep watching to see
the small details you missed in
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore
what is a wizard to do without a bird to
save the day go back to 2002 when harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
premiered fans had just met dumbledore's
phoenix fox who played a significant
role in harry destroying tom riddle's
diary and saving ginny fox carrying
harry ron jenny and even lockhart out of
the chamber even made it onto the cover
of the american version of the book now
with the events of the secrets of
dumbledore phoenixes are more integral
to the plot than ever however it's not a
phoenix that offers the chamber of
secrets easter egg for the beginning of
the movie newt faces off against
grindelwald's followers mirroring the
fox scene from decades later a
dragon-like creature called a wyvern
flies newt his suitcase and his beasts
away from the area as it puffs up like a
dragon puffer fish it's a significant
homage to fox who might just be
credence's phoenix
there's no denying that sirius black is
one of the greatest characters to appear
in the harry potter books and films but
is also deeply misunderstood here's a
man who's had his reputation obliterated
by a supposed friend and was tortured in
azgaban for 12 years yet despite his
deep trauma and the overwhelming
depression he sometimes faces sirius
black still manages to be a good person
we've all got both slight
and dark inside of us
what matters is the part we choose to
act on
but between his wisdom and sadness
sirius has an unparalleled zest for life
and an infectious yearning for mischief
he's everything grindelwald could be if
he wanted but the budding dictator
chooses to kill people instead much of
the third harry potter book and movie
hinges on the manhunt for sirius with
hogsmeade diagon alley and hogwarts
littered with moving wanted posters
now the secrets of dumbledore is giving
fans deja vu with grindelwald's snowy
hogsmeade wanted signs however
grindelwald is exonerated for the crimes
he committed while sirius must go into
hiding until his death even in the
wizarding world life isn't fair
who needs flying cars when you can have
magical trains some of the secrets of
dumbledore references to harry potter
are pretty on the nose but it doesn't
make them any less charming while the
wizarding world films often focus on the
beauty of humanity they also encourage
fans to appreciate the breathtaking
beauty around them in nature the idea
for the hogwarts express came to jk
rowling as she rode on the very train
that inspired her to write harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone and in its way
the express gives new students to
hogwarts a glimpse of magic before they
even raise their wands for the first
time the secrets of dumbledore had a
similar idea when newt's ragtag group of
misfits meet on a train while it flies
through snowy mountains it may be a
fairly plain looking train but the
homage to the hogwarts express is
palpable
dumbledore is known for his sage wisdom
and even 50 years younger than his first
appearance in the harry potter universe
he doesn't disappoint
the future headmaster has gone through
more than a few internal struggles and
successfully fought off a lingering
thirst for power with or without you
i'll burn down their world
dumbledore has long since ditched the
for the greater good mantra he lived by
in his time with grindelwald but he
still occasionally falls into that
mentality the most devastating example
of this kind of lapse is his secretive
training of harry to prepare him to take
down voldemort he went through with this
risky plan knowing full well that harry
might not survive the conflict despite
his many flaws dumbledore gives harry
some food for thought after cedric's
goblet of fire death dark and difficult
times lie ahead
soon we must all face the choice between
what is right and what is easy
of course he's had a long time to
perfect the sentiment between the events
of the secrets of dumbledore and goblet
of fire he gives newt a similar message
to relay to vogel who holds
grindelwald's fate in his hands so
what's the message do what is right not
what is easy later answering the
question of why grindelwald can run for
supreme mugwump despite being a wannabe
dictator dumbledore says because vogel
chose easy over right apparently
dumbledore was a bit pithier in his
youth but the sentiment is the same
in the deathly hallows grindelwald and
dumbledore's previous obsession with the
fabled relics of the peverell brothers
comes to light not only was grindelwald
on the hunt for the elder wand the
invisibility cloak and the resurrection
stone but dumbledore found himself on
this quest for power as well until this
point in the series grindelwald's
hollows obsession goes relatively
unmentioned beyond the reveal that he
obtained the elder wand from esteemed
wand maker grigorovich yet it looks like
the hollows may play a greater role in
grindelwald's continued quest for
domination over the muggle world in the
secrets of dumbledore fans learn that
each wizard running for supreme mugwump
has a symbol associated with them
wizards cast their vote for the next
leader by firing off their nominee
symbol from their wand in a blink and
you'll miss it scene it's clear that the
deathly hallow symbol inspired
grindelwald's mark the hollow symbol
lies in the middle of two g's with a
more pronounced elder wand nestled
distinctly in the middle along with the
hollows reference the symbol is eerily
similar to the death eater's dark mark
right down to the lime green color
though attacked by his werewolf
professor and discovering that his best
friend was sleeping with a 40 year old
rat harry's most traumatic experience in
the prisoner of azgaban might be when
his care of magical creatures book tries
to eat him when the students call out
hagrid for his bizarre choice of biting
books the giant defends himself he calls
the books cute and instructs the
students to stroke the spine to prevent
their textbook from attacking as it
turns out the wizarding world isn't
quite finished with the monster book of
monsters when dumbledore's army sets off
to confuse grindelwald and get the chill
into the election all but one group
member carries a bewitched suitcase that
looks like newts
amongst other things one has a golden
snitch another has pastries and yet
another melts of course there's also one
with colorful textbooks some of the
titles include sonnet of a sorcerer
which jinxes readers into speaking in
limericks forever then there is have a
fiesta in a bottle and extreme
incantations but alongside the colorful
creations is the dreaded the monster
book of monsters which means that
harry's textbook is quite old it may
have even been released before newt's
book fantastic beasts and where to find
them
if there's one thing the fantastic bee
series doesn't need it's romanticizing
severus snape's creepy behavior toward
lily potter in deathly hallows fans
learn about snape's obsessive love for
lily through snape's memories sure snape
turned his back on voldemort but only
after the dictator killed lily snape was
fine with her family getting killed as
long as she survived snape's pining over
the woman who turned him down decades
ago is endless and ridiculous to the
point where he bullies her child just
because harry looks like james
when dumbledore asks if he loves lily
after all this time the potions master
responds
this is stalker behavior but even harry
himself romanticizes snape's actions
when he names his second son albus
severus in the secrets of dumbledore
following the reveal that credence is
aberforth's son it's unclear why
aberfort never bothered to look for him
when credence finally meets aberforth he
asks did you ever think of me paying
homage to snape aberforth says always
abraford tells credence to come home
only taking responsibility as a father
when his son is dying and there's
nothing that can save him in some ways
snape and aberforth are alike and not in
good ways
[Music]
there's no better title for the third
installment of the fantastic beasts
series than the secrets of dumbledore it
turns out the future headmaster of
hogwarts is harder to read than a hexed
poetry book his instinct is to keep
everything to himself until the moment
when he needs his ally's help
dumbledore's got a real checkered
history of being able to
encourage people to do crazy things
the upshot of this is that he has a
wealth of knowledge about the wizarding
world that he keeps quiet along with
more than a few wickedly powerful
gadgets that he either procured or
created himself one such gadget takes
the form of a stopwatch the first harry
potter book describes it as a very odd
watch it had 12 hands but no numbers
instead little planets were moving
around the edge dumbledore uses it to
tell time and it makes an appearance in
the first and fifth books however it
never shows up on screen until the
secrets of dumbledore here dumbledore
clearly uses the pocket watch to find
credence's location and he has a picture
of the wizard on the stopwatch it's no
surprise that the mysterious looking
watch would have a use beyond telling
time but it's unclear if it works to
track down just anyone or if it's a
dumbledore heirloom specifically made to
keep tabs on his bloodline either way
it's fun to see an aspect of the book
come to life on screen for the first
time
the wizarding world is chock full of
secret passageways and unique ways that
the magical community separates their
world from the muggles for instance
hogwarts has a protection spell that
causes muggles to see a danger sign atop
ruins when it comes to the entrance to
diagon alley hagrid shows harry how to
enter without apparating or using flue
powder he simply taps a combination of
bricks and the wall opens up we haven't
seen this method of entry in any other
magical location since then but the
secrets of dumbledore brings it back
when dumbledore's original army goes to
the german ministry the bricks are just
a tad bit sleeker but the process is the
same
cockroach clusters are peanut type candy
made of you guessed it cockroaches the
bizarre treats are purchased more often
to troll unsuspecting hogwarts
classmates than to actually eat and
enjoy ron fails to trick fred into
eating them and as it turns out the
slytherins in the secrets of dumbledore
have a similar idea when jacob hangs out
in the great hall some nice slytherins
offer him candy after dumbledore
declares that he never cared much for
cockroach clusters jacob glares at the
mischievous slytherins despite
dumbledore's distaste for cockroach
clusters and earwax birdie bots he
chooses cockroach clusters as a password
for his office about 50 years later
maybe he just misses his muggle friend
movie fans were introduced to the world
of harry potter when dumbledore used his
illuminator a light magical object of
his own making to darken privet drive
for a while it seemed like the object's
only use was to suck up and release the
light from various light sources then in
the deathly hallows ron inherits the
deluminator from dumbledore not only
does the object control light sources
but it seems to be a listening device
too after ron bales and harry and
hermione during their horcrux search he
hears snippets of conversations from the
object when harry and hermione mention
his name even weirder it acts like a
port key to apparate ron back to his
friends when he realizes leaving was a
mistake so i took it
clicked it
this tiny ball of light appeared
the full extent of the deluminator's
powers is never fully explored in the
original books and movies but the
secrets of dumbledore provide some
insight into the device's capabilities
dumbledore uses it in his battle with
credence and later grindelwald where the
object does something very peculiar it
seems like the deluminator takes both
sets of dueling wizards to a parallel
plane adjacent to the real world but it
looks like a darker mirrored version
it seems like people on the physical
plane can't see what happens during this
duel however one thing's for sure the
deluminator has quite a few tricks up
its sleeve and so does dumbledore
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you